Not everything you see in movies is real,
but it’s hard to fake chemistry… or is
it? These co-stars prove that you don’t
have to actually like someone to convince
the world you’re BFFs. What’s a little
leg licking between friends? You’ll have
to watch to the end to find out.
During the filming of "The Fate of the Furious"
there was an alleged beef between two of the
film's biggest stars: Vin Diesel and Dwayne
"The Rock" Johnson.
"Just like in life you have different philosophies
and people have different philosophies - different
fundamental philosophies on how you do things
- and again, the most important thing is just
the movies."
After the production, Johnson took to social
media to praise only some of his co-stars,
writing in a since deleted post -
"My female co stars are always amazing, and
I love 'em. My male co stars, however, are
a different story. Some conduct themselves
as stand-up men and true professionals, while
others don't."
Although it was unclear exactly who The Rock
was referring to, the aim of that jab most
likely included Diesel.
Diesel addressed it to clear the air, telling
USA Today -
"I don't think the world really realizes how
close we are, in a weird way. I think some
things may be blown out of proportion. [...] In
my house, he's Uncle Dwayne."
Allegedly, Ryan Reynolds had trouble with
Wesley Snipes during the filming of 2004's
"Blade: Trinity." But then again, apparently
so did the entire cast and crew.
Journalist Chris Parry, who at the time was
working on an article about the production
of the film, spent some time on the set and
spoke to crew members anonymously. One source
talked about Snipes and Reynolds' relationship,
saying -
"He refers to Ryan Reynolds as 'that c------'
or 'tell that c------ to get out of my eyeline,'
and 'tell that c------ to get his lines right.'"
Snipes reportedly was difficult with everyone
on set, and there have been rumors that he
even at one point strangled the film's director,
David Goyer. According to The Hollywood Reporter,
Goyer never confirmed the incident but he
did say -
"I have tremendous respect for Wesley as an
actor. He used to be a friend. We're not friends
anymore. I don't think anyone involved in
that film had a good experience; certainly,
I didn't."
2000's "Charlie's Angels" was a box office
hit, bolstered by a star-studded cast that
included Cameron Diaz, Drew Barrymore, and
Lucy Liu as the Angels, and Bill Murray as
the pseudo-manager, Bosley. However, in reality
the team didn't seem as connected as they
did in the movie.
The story goes that there was a rewrite of
one scene, and Murray wasn't happy with it.
For some reason, he took his frustration out
on Liu — despite her claiming not to have
anything to do with the changes. She addressed
the incident during an interview on the Los
Angeles Times podcast "Asian Enough." According
to Liu, Murray began insulting her, and she
didn't back down. She said -
"I stood up for myself, and I don't regret
it. Because no matter how low on the totem
pole you may be or wherever you came from,
there's no need to condescend or to put other
people down."
The two have seemingly rekindled their professional
relationship, but Liu still thinks she did
the right thing in standing up to Murray.
It's hard to pinpoint the exact reason for
the longstanding feud between "Sex and the
City" co-stars Sarah Jessica Parker and Kim
Cattrall, but it's clear that the two weren't
the best of friends on set. In an interview
with Piers Morgan, Cattrall explained why
she didn't want to return for the reboot series,
saying she had been portrayed as "demanding
or a diva" in the press. She also singled
out Parker's behavior.
"I think she could have been nicer. I really
think she could have been nicer. I don't know
what her issue is."
Tensions escalated later when, after a death
in the family, Cattrall posted a message to
her Instagram directed at Parker; it read:
"Your continuous reaching out is a painful
reminder of how cruel you really were then
and now. Let me make this VERY clear. (If
I haven't already.) You are not my family.
You are not my friend. So I'm writing to tell
you one last time to stop exploiting our tragedy
in order to restore your 'nice girl' persona."
At the same time, Parker has maintained that
she never had it out for Cattrall, saying
to Elle -
"I don't think anybody wants to believe that
I love Kim. I adore her. I wouldn't have done
the movie without her."
One of Meryl Streep's first starring roles
was alongside another current veteran, Dustin
Hoffman, in 1979's "Kramer vs. Kramer." And
Streep claimed to the New York Times that
Hoffman went too far while filming.
The incident happened during a scene in which
Hoffman's character slapped Streep's, and
apparently the slap was a little too real.
Referring to the scene, Streep said -
"This is tricky because when you're an actor,
you're in a scene, you have to feel free.
I'm sure that I have inadvertently hurt people
in physical scenes. [...] But this was my
first movie, and it was my first take in my
first movie, and he just slapped me. And you
see it in the movie."
For Hoffman's part, he did admit that he was
difficult to work with during the production,
and that his problems in his personal life
affected his coworkers on set.
Although they teamed up onscreen, Jim Carrey
and Tommy Lee Jones weren't quite partners
in crime on the set of 1995's "Batman Forever,"
and much of that animosity came from Jones.
According to Carrey, there was one incident
that spoke to Jones' feelings about him. During
an appearance on the late Norm MacDonald's
talkshow, Carrey explained that during a day
off while filming the movie, the two happened
to be sitting in the same restaurant. Carrey
decided to go over and say hello, which apparently
wasn't something Jones wanted.
"And he went to hug me and said, 'I hate you.
I really don't like you.'"
Carrey then asked what the problem was, and
said -
"I pulled up a chair, which probably wasn't
smart, and he said, 'I cannot sanction your buffoonery.'"
Of course, as The Riddler, Carrey's character
came with a certain amount of 'buffoonery.'
But apparently the man behind the green, question-marked
jumpsuit had a little too much silliness on-set
for Jones' liking.
Marlon Brando and Sophia Loren starred alongside
each other in the 1967 Charlie Chaplin-directed
comedy "A Countess from Hong Kong." According
to Loren, Brando got a bit too touchy-feely,
and she responded by letting him know that
was not okay.
She explained in her autobiography, "Yesterday,
Today, Tomorrow: My Life," writing -
"All of a sudden, he put his hands on me.
I turned in all tranquility and blew in his
face, like a cat stroked the wrong way and
said, 'Don't you ever dare to do that again.
Never again!'"
Although Brando didn't do anything like that
again while filming the movie, it made the
rest of the production uncomfortable for Loren.
She admitted that it was difficult to work
with him afterwards.
Gene Kelly's "Singin' In The Rain" co-star
Debbie Reynolds revealed that the twosome's
working relationship was much more fraught
than their onscreen rapport. She wrote in
her memoir -
"He came to rehearsals and criticized everything
I did and never gave me a word of encouragement,"
Reynolds continued that, when it was time
to shoot the kissing scenes with Kelly, things
got even more uncomfortable, writing -
"Gene took me tightly in his arms [...] and
shoved his tongue down my throat. 'Eeew! What
was that?' I screeched, breaking free of his
grasp and spitting."
And to make matters a bit more awkward, Reynolds
was just 19 at the time, while Kelly was 37.
Reynolds went on to write -
"I was an innocent kid who had never been
French-kissed. It felt like an assault."
Behind the scenes of 1983's "Terms of Endearment,"
there were rumors about how tension between
Shirley MacLaine and Debra Winger manifested
on set in some very strange ways. During an
appearance on "Watch What Happens Live," Winger
was asked about rumors that she tried to pass
gas towards MacLaine or that she licked her
leg while the latter was trying to film a
love scene with Jack Nicholson.
"Was any of that true?"
"You mean you wanna just go in there and say
is there something true in there?"
"Yeah."
"There's something true in there."
Despite the fighting, the duo of acting greats
still hold each other in high regard — at
least professionally, with Winger telling
The New York Times -
"I can't deny that we fought. [...] But I
think there was always a respect between the
two of us."
The grudge match between Hollywood icons Bette
Davis and Joan Crawford is so legendary that
it was turned into a TV show in 2017, aptly
titled "Feud: Bette and Joan."
So, what was the issue? Well, a lot of things.
The two reportedly fought over nearly everything,
including lovers, movie roles, fame, and parenting
— all before ever working together. It all
came to a head when the duo starred alongside
each other in 1962's "What Ever Happened to
Baby Jane?" Entertainment Weekly writes that
Davis once said -
"The best time I ever had with Joan Crawford
was when I pushed her down the stairs."
In a scene, in which Davis was supposed to
fake kick Crawford in the head, she actually
did make contact, and it resulted in three
stitches.
But Crawford got her revenge during a scene
where Davis had to pull her out of bed. Crawford
secretly wore a heavy weightlifter's belt
underneath her costume, knowing that Davis
had a bad back.
Even when Crawford died in 1977 of a heart
attack, the fight lived on. Upon hearing of
her rival's passing, Davis allegedly said
-
"You should never say bad things about the
dead, only good. Joan Crawford is dead. Good."
Kenny Baker and Anthony Daniels, better known
as their iconic characters R2-D2 and C-3PO
respectively, weren't as close as their iconic
onscreen bond made it seem. Baker has publicly
said that Daniels disrespected him on-set
by calling him insulting names.
Daniels responded to the claims, telling his
side of the story in 2019 to the Daily Express,
saying -
"Kenny decided that he wanted to say unkind,
unpleasant, rude, hurtful things. It got worse
and worse."
When the suits came on, however, it was all
business and easy to put aside their differences.
Daniels explained -
"The fact is we didn't really appear or interact
together. He was in a box he couldn't do anything
with. He couldn't hear me. He never made a
sound."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
on screen partners are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one.